allison mack sentenced to three years
behind bars and a 20 thousand dollar
fine
for her role in the nexium sex cult
there's a lot of twists and turns
understanding these ideas and then
living them we're changing the world
prosecutors asked the judge to give mack
a reduced sentence because of the quote
substantial assistance she provided with
their investigation
into the cult its leader keith renery
was sentenced to 120 years in prison in
october
for his role that included sex
trafficking women what was your reaction
to the sentencing today of allison mack
initially i was pretty shocked i'm still
kind of like processing it all to be
honest
we spoke with one of the cult's victims
india oxenburg
she's the daughter of dynasty star
catherine oxenburg india says she was
raped
starved and branded with ranieri and max
initials
as detailed in two different
documentaries including seduced on stars
did you help brand india oxenburg have
you had a chance to talk to your mom
about it
yes i have and um and we're both
actually really
like please is not the right word but
validated
setting a standard that really
abuse is not going to be tolerated and
it is not going to be allowed
you need to get out of there now we're
going to see a lot of characters really
change and sort of make some
life-changing decisions alisonback is
best known for her role on smallville
she pleaded guilty in 2019 to charges
related to manipulating women
into becoming sex slaves she's been on
house arrest
while awaiting today's sentencing
anything you'd like to say to the people
who you've heard allison put out a
statement apologizing do you accept that
apology
i do it does not change the past for me
it really just informs me about her and
where she's at in her own healing
process
what would you say to her today if you
can speak to her it feels really simple
but i just
wish her well i don't wish her
any ill will it's not necessary i don't
need to do that
i i'm moving on and i certainly hope
that she does
[Music]
allison is also required to have three
years of supervised release after she
serves her time behind bars